we've been chatting and i've been
chatting the whole time with the
hilarious nicole fire about love life
and all the things
and um
we've been talking uh about all the
things you do nailed it um wipe out with
john cena and now you're also on grand
cru which people are saying is like a
new
friends which is quite the uh
comparison yes exactly what a lovely
wonderful mantle really nice to be on um
okay tell us about your character it's
about a group of friends and you're i
play nikki nikki is um a professional
she's fun she's full of advice but she
also makes mistakes um
she hangs out with yeah i'm like so far
i'm relating uh-huh yeah and she hangs
out with her brother noah and his group
of friends from like college and it's
just like set in a wine bar because you
know wine is fun it gets you drunk and
what a nice time well i love that nicole
is everyone's like dream best friend who
always tells it like it is do you like
people who tell it like it is i do like
people who tell it like it is but then
sometimes you're like i didn't ask
well funny you should say that because
that is a perfect story dovetailing into
the fact that we actually have some
guests here today that we want to get
into it with okay what kind of life
advice are you in i'm totally in let's
do this well then it's time to face the
fire with nicole byer
okay first up best friends danielle and
daisy
they have a little drama
ladies
oh my god give it to us dish what's
going on um so basically i'm like the
planner we have awesome friends we have
awesome ideas we're all professionals
working moms the whole nine
and basically what happens is just like
for today
uh the idea was there but like who's
going to make it happen and it kind of
always falls into my lap like oh i want
to go skiing or i want to go camping
it's like all right cool then it's like
dead silence i'm like
and then what like should i do it yeah
that's our problem
yeah that's how we got here today
because she planned it she put out the
text the emails you know and so
um we're just trying to figure out
what to do how i can get some
help yeah
okay so the issue is you like planning
things but you're tired of planning i am
tired of planning okay so you need to
when you come up with an idea delegate
to your friends be like you're going to
do this you're going to do this you're
going to do this by this date and then
check in is it done
i like it i like it a lot get new
friends
okay next we have laura what is your
dilemma hi
so i have a bit of an awkward venmo
scenario that i've come across a few
times where
i will be going out with a bunch of
friends and we're at dinner having a
blast having a great time and then by
the time that the bill comes someone
pays and the usual
venmo us request us let us know how much
we owe you then i get the venmo request
and i see i'm looking at it like did we
pay the bill twice i don't
this is way over what i thought it was
going to be and then i realized that
it's also partly because i don't
normally drink
so you know as where everybody's
knocking back drinks which is great i
can keep up i don't drink so um should i
say something usually i just shrug it
off and just pay it you know it's
whatever but at the same time you kind
of feel like
what's fair well i'm excited to hear
your answer nicole okay
[Laughter]
at first i was like is your friend
making money off friends
criminal but smart but okay so you don't
drink i think it's okay to say i didn't
drink like if everyone was drinking i'm
like split it whatever but if you're
like truly not drinking drinks are
expensive
so you shouldn't be paying for other
people's drinks i would just send a
venmo for less and be like oh hey i had
no drinks i think it's okay to pay less
right i agree 100
i love you and i agree
um
i am totally with you well thank you so
much for your question and thank you for
your answer i love you thank you
um
i mean
you have swept through here like a
breath of funny fresh air
and thank you
like
people need
funny they need honest
thank you
thank you thank you so much thank you so
much nicole buyer you can get more
nicole by watching grand cru on nbc
wipeout on tbs
nailed it on netflix and her podcast
obviously why won't you date me come on
nicole meyer thank you so much
[Music]